Recently I took a job working at
a camp with at risk boys were out.
Well there I will live and work as a
counselor and a house with the kids.
Any advice for working with young
people with behavioral issues?
Okay.
Uh,
yeah.
Okay.
It depends on what the
behavioral issues are.
So I don't know what our risk meets,
but I,
so I,
I can't be too specific.
But what I can tell you is that
almost nothing beats listening.
You know,
like take a kid for a walk,
let him talk.
Like listen to them,
ask them questions.
You know,
because most disturbed people,
and maybe even most people don't actually
have anyone they can talk to and they
need to talk first of all,
to find out that someone
actually cares enough to listen.
So it's sort of like a validation of the
fact that they exist and second so that
they can sort out their own thoughts.
So as a beginning counselor,
the best thing you can do is listen.
You don't want to give advice really.
You know,
because what you want,
you can ask questions that might lead
someone in an advisable direction.
But the problem with giving advice is
that people are much more likely to
remember something and to implement it
if they've thought it up in their own
words.
I think that actually produces a
kind of neurological transformation.
The idea has to be in
gendered from within.
It's one of the prime dicta of,
of psychoanalytic theory for example.
And I think it's a really good one.
So,
uh,
yeah,
when and with regards,
so Brendan Trista says
trippy snakes and retinas.
Yeah.
Like it's really specific.
So this woman named,
um,
okay.
No,
I probably can't remember her name.
Me and he either she,
she wrote a book about trees and serpents.
Uh,
she's a UCLA professor.
Um,
the fruit,
the tree and the serpent,
I think it's called.
She showed quite clearly that not only
do our retinas say directly detects
snakes,
but they do a better job in
the bottom half of the retina.
And that we're really good at detecting
the a camouflage patterns that are
characteristic of snakes to snakes
have these like diamond patterns,
which are very,
very rare.
And we have specialized
circuitry for detecting those.
And there was recent research conducted
that showed that children six months old
who had never been exposed to anything,
even resembling a snake,
had an automatic response to snakes.
And so it actually seems to be innate,
not just,
uh,
not just easily learned.
So that's really quite interesting.